I'm getting an inside look at all three
NBC Chicago shows beginning with Chicago
med let's go scrub in Chicago med anyone
out here is there anything worse than a
hospital waiting room oh but there's a
Kids Corner now come back to your hands
okay can't start with you here
take its finger god I kind of got it
this is harder than it looks
it is shaken okay why am i nervous look
at I can't even get the glove on right
don't trust me with your life folks so
I'm not saving this guy's life ha ha oh
my god this looks so real yeah he's gone
I I tried I'm not a doctor I just play
one on et all right so I'm a little
queasy not gonna lie I'm in the right
field don't belong in do are should not
be a doctor let's go see if being a
police officers in my future
we're entering the interrogation room
this is where it all goes down folks
looks like a ruin not that I would know
by any means but uh looks pretty
realistic to me I love this mirror
though ooh better check that hairspray
light okay wait people look at this
mirror
how often have you done that how do I
make this look pretty good my convincing
cop you know beats the alternative I
could be on the other side of this table
but all right we're gonna see what I've
looked like in the fire department about
that copy Thanks
alright I'm any my day after Chicago
fire set to find out what all the fuss
is about beginning in chief Boden's
office that's right the big boss
[Music]
I like how this feels days that long
arms are you guys I'm not gonna lie the
cast members told me Chicago Fire has
the hardest job of all the Chicago shows
but so far I haven't seen anyone here
alright guys I'm actually amazed because
this is a soundstage but look how real
this fire station looks in fact if you
follow me this way
I found the sleeping quarters perfect
timing because I could use a nap I'm not
gonna lie I think I'm just gonna Park it
just for a sec all right just one
because it's really hard being a
firefighter
I can tell oh alright it's been a long
day hitting every Chicago set I'm
thirsty
I hear Chicago's pretty well known for
their brews so it's a four beer well
listen you guys said you're the
hardest-working bunch of the Chicago
family but I've seen nothing of beds and
now we're drinking brews so my brother
the hardest-working crew is going to
need a place to sleep too far to take a
nap something there's way more beds on
Med than there are on our show okay
they're literally called they call
themselves Club Med over there they all
say they all agree with you guys by the
way yeah these are pretty much pajamas
that's exactly by the way figs calm
beautiful square Z no point in arguing
to be honest with you I mean what is
what would be the counter-argument are
they not pajamas we earned these drinks
been a long day right oh wait they say
to uh don't forget to tip your bartender
so thank you very much oh thank you wait
this isn't a real beer the only tip he's
got in
all right guys thank you for having me
thank you brother
[Applause]
[Music]